what's up aviators and welcome to
Private Pilot ground lesson 2 from free
pilot training I'm Josh and this is my
father-in-law Mike and today I've got a
super important lesson for you on how an
airplane creates
[Music]
lift if you want to learn how to fly you
really need to have a good understanding
of some basic aerodynamic principles in
the last lesson we talked about the four
forces that affect an aircraft in flight
but today I want to focus on lift I mean
I'm no expert but I'd say that lift is a
pretty important part of flying wouldn't
you now you may have noticed this but
airplanes have these things called wings
and wings are an important part of
creating lift actually on most airplanes
they're the only part that creates lift
anyway our wings use two things to
create lift relative wind and the shape
of the wing now I don't want to insult
your intelligence but as I mentioned in
the last video lift is an upward force
that opposes the weight weight of an
aircraft and everything on board
remember in steady unaccelerated flight
lift equals weight but if we want to
climb or create more lift we have to do
something we'll get to that more in just
a minute but for now let's take a look
at how an airplane creates lift now
there are really two ways that an
airplane creates lift and we're going to
discuss both but for the written exam
they're mainly going to want you to know
about something called Bern's principle
so let's take a closer look at that in a
nutshell berle's principle states that
as the velocity of a moving fluid
increases the pressure within that fluid
decreases narrow areas like this Force
the fluid to increase its speed you'll
sometimes hear these narrow areas
referred to as Venturi and these Venturi
areas decrease the pressure when they
increase the velocity of a fluid in
other words this increase in speed
causes a decrease in pressure now just
like an aventuri the curved surface of
the upper Wing forces the air on top of
the wing to travel faster than the air
on the bottom of the wing this creates
an area of lower pressure on top of the
wing and an area of high pressure on the
bottom of the wing and what do you think
happens when you have low pressure on
the top of the wing and high air
pressure on the bottom that's right the
high air pressure pushes the wing up
which actually creates an upward force
and this is what we're calling lift now
to increase that lift we can do a few
different things one of the ways is to
increase the speed of the air going over
the top of the wing we call this air
going over and under the wing relative
wind because this is a combination of
multiple different types of wind you've
got wind that's caused by the thrust of
the aircraft and as we increase the
thrust that our aircraft is producing
the speed of that air going over the
wings increases as well then you've got
something called prop wash which is
actually the backwards wind that's
caused by the propeller pushing the
aircraft forward this would be like a
fan blowing on you when it's hot
outside you also have the actual wind
outside that you have absolutely no
control over sometimes you have a
headwind that helps you create more lift
and sometimes you have a Tailwind that
takes some of your relative wind this is
actually one of the reasons why we take
off and land into the wind this gives us
the most amount of relative wind
possible so our wings can produce plenty
of lift the other thing we can do is to
change the shape of the wing and we can
do that a couple different ways now
another name for this side angle view of
the wing is called an air foil and when
we change the air foil design and make
it more curved on Top This increases
something that we call the camber of the
wing this simply means that the air on
top has to travel a farther distance
than the air on the bottom so must
travel faster in order to meet the air
on the other side this creates even less
pressure on the top of the wing which
creates more lift but this actually
increases the drag on the airplane as
well so you can't fly as fast so
increasing the camber increases our lift
but it also creates more induced drag
one of the ways we can increase the
camber on our wings is by lowering the
flaps on our aircraft this lengthens the
upper surface of the wing which creates
more lift but it also increases the drag
on our airplane another way we can
increase the lift that our wing produces
is to increase the angle of attack now
I'm going to go into a lot more detail
on this in the next lesson but in a
nutshell this just means that we're
raising the nose of our airplane so that
the relative wind has to travel a
farther distance around the upper
surface of the wing as you can see our
lift is increased when we do this
because that wind on the top has to
travel a further distance just like it
did when we increased the camber but
once again increasing our angle of
attack increases our induced drag
because we're exposing a bigger portion
of our wing to the relative wind another
thing that creates lift is Newton's
third law which says that for every
action there's an equal and opposite
reaction now we know that Boli's
principle creates lift by creating lower
air pressure on the upper surface of the
wing but in addition to that air can
strike the lower surface of the wing and
push it up when relative wind hits the
lower surface of the wing it pushes the
wing up and back and as you can see when
we raise our wing to a higher angle of
attack there's more surface area on the
bottom of the wing that's exposed this
allows the of wind to push the wing up
and back even harder so as we increase
our angle of attack lift increases but
drag also increases when we do that as
well right now you might be thinking who
cares I want to fly airplanes I don't
want to be a NASA engineer well me
neither but check this out now that we
know the things that cause lift we can
start using that knowledge to control
the aircraft right now I'm trimmed out
for level unaccelerated flight but I
want to increase my lift what's
something I can do well one of the
options is to increase my air speed I'm
not pulling back on the Yol I'm simply
increasing my air speed watch what
happens to my altitude when I do that
okay I'm I'm trimmed out for level fly
the airplane just kind of flying itself
here all right so I'm going to increase
power and increase my air which will
increase my air speed and watch what
happens to my lift so power's increased
let SWAT the airplane I'm using the
rudder to stay straight ahead here but
notice we're starting to get a climb
look at this all I did was increase this
thrust and that increased our air speed
and that increased the lift that came
that's coming over the top of the Wings
okay so what's another way we can
increase our lift well I can increase
the camber of my wings so let's lower
the flaps and see what happens all right
so it looks like we're in the wide Arc
I'm going to go ahead and lower these
flaps see what happens
here notice how the airplane is starting
to climb
here okay that's all we had to do is
lower those flaps to increase the camber
of the wing all right we got a good air
speed I'll start raising those flaps
back up when we first did that you
probably noticed the air speed yes we
were creating more lift but we're also
inducing more drag so that caus the air
speed to
decrease and once again I can increase
my angle of attack and this just means
to pitch the nose of the aircraft up and
you'll notice that when I pitch up and
increase my angle of attack that my air
speed is starting to decrease here as
well because I'm inducing more drag all
right so we're not climbing we're at
2600 ft here all right
so all we got to do here is pitch up and
just watch that air speed bleed
off I'm increasing my angle of attack so
my air speed is bleeding
off so I'm creating more lift but I'm
also causing a decrease in air speed now
you know how an airplane creates lift
and in my next lesson we're going to
talk about something you could do that
could cause a rapid loss of lift and if
you're not expecting it it can be Pretty
stinking SC
and I'll put that video right here when
you're ready to get
learned